the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media look if you guys want to
help this show then subscribe just hit
subscribe it's a free way to help the
show throws us out into the algorithm
people get to see us more
um and it costs you nothing all right it
means everything to us over here and if
you've got to have more then you gotta
check out the patreon go back watch the
Josh Wolf episode we just did where we
highlight some of our favorite episodes
this [__] is insane it's all your
stories it's your show it's called the
Honeydew with y'all it's five bucks a
month all right if you sign up for a
year you get like over a month for free
um you get the Honeydew a day early you
get an ad free at no additional cost and
I'm telling you right now if you know
someone or if you have a story that has
to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully
we'll get to do an episode together all
right if you're looking for a new
podcast just listen to go binge the crab
Feast it's a great Library it's free
it's out there you got all kinds of
crazy stories on there today's guest had
a wild story on there if I remember
correctly all right uh now you guys know
what we do over here we highlight the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers and I'm
very excited to have this guest back on
the Honeydew ladies and gentlemen
welcome Kelsey cook welcome back
thank you definitely check out Kelsey's
crab feast episode that's the original
story I still get people leaving
comments on Instagram like [__] the crab
feast and manicure tool and all that
[__] yeah and it's on um this is not
happening you did it yeah it's [__]
great yeah
um well welcome back and before we get
into anything today please plug promote
everything Kelsey cook yeah so um you
can listen to this self-helpless podcast
on all podcast platforms I'm on tour
right now you can go to kelseycook.com
get tour date tickets at Kelsey comedy
on all socials and then my special is
coming out it will be available
everywhere on YouTube March 9th but it's
going to be coming out a little early as
well
um for purchase on February 28th on my
website so kelseycook.com you'll get um
like a signed poster free audio album
download as well I love it doing a
little bundle if you want to do it that
way but it will be free everywhere on
March 9th prior to that you can get it a
week early straight through what's your
website kelseycook.com boom I [__]
love that good for you very smart thank
you yeah YouTube seems to be a good uh a
good way to do it I mean it depends it
depends you know when you have a show
like I have when you talk about women
have come on talked about rape well when
you put the word rape into anything they
[__] demonetized and so our argument
is how do we educate people about this
right if we can't talk about this right
we've had incest we've had rape we've
had domestic violence we've had you name
it right trauma we've had all of it and
YouTube's like nah we're not we're gonna
demonetize your episode we're still
gonna run ads in it but you can't
[__] get it yeah so it's it's a
little challenging but I'm sorry I
didn't even think about that but I
wonder about our specials like are they
gonna demonetize those because of
content language some you know that
voice yeah [__] but go watch her special
yeah there's definitely some [__] jokes
on there so
all right let's get into what you want
to talk about today because you came
with something that was is sort of new
is it not is it recent
um well it's like it's ongoing but it
started a couple years ago I just it's
been a recent thing that I've decided to
talk more publicly about it because I
really kind of kept it to myself except
for close family and friends the last
couple years but um my mom got diagnosed
with dementia two years ago and can I
can I just ask you this yeah of course
what happens when you're like what do
they first see
where they say no you do have it is it a
scan of the brain where they can tell
like gray area or something like that
yeah plaques um atrophy stuff like that
so they had done an MRI but uh basically
what how it had started so 2020 was such
a hard year for everybody and I think if
there were things that were underlying
with people they got exacerbated and so
I was living in La at the time and I had
noticed some kind of Behavioral changes
with my mom little things but nothing
that
caused too much concern nothing that I
was like I think she should go to the
doctors just kind of like huh that's
kind of that's a little different and
then at the end of 2020 I decided to
move back to Spokane which is where I'm
from originally because things were so
shut down here that's where your mom is
yeah and
I had gotten gotten an apartment there I
was living there for three weeks and
then went over to my mom's and found her
face down on her living room floor oh no
um or was there a bedroom floor and uh
you just went to visit and that's how
you found her holy [__] are you
terrified when you walk in that my mom's
dead yeah yeah just like fully like face
and you don't know how long you don't
know anything oh my God your mind's got
to be going a mile a minute right I had
talked to her the night before on the
phone and I could tell that she was like
not not doing great uh and I was like
okay I'll come over in the morning and
she overnight had basically become
septic she was like about to her white
blood cell count was through the roof
and so I called 9-1-1 they an ambulance
came we went to the hospital and she had
a perforated stomach ulcer oh my God her
gallbladder was inflamed and full of
stones and she had covered
so what what was it that ripped her
stomach open so she um she had been
taking a lot of Tylenol Advil and suds
to help with
um sciatica pain and that can cause
ulcers if it's going on for too long so
that happened and so they wanted to do
emergency surgery to repair everything
but what we didn't know is that she had
this underlying dementia and when you
have
um anesthesia done it can accelerate
dementia oh is that right so she came
out of surgery a completely different
person what like noticeably
like like you could tell completely
um she like thought she had time
traveled she was oh man like not she was
not there she was not on this planet
and I gotta say this yeah as a person
who just went under anesthesia three
times yeah I think I time traveled a
little bit
I think that's why I travel a little bit
I mean yeah well and in fact like I'm
scared to say some [__] no please
you have to say this you know we have to
like that's the thing is I that's why
I'm wanting to talk about it a little
more is because like I was isolating
myself and that had become I think
unhealthy for my mental health to be
going through this in a vacuum and not
opening myself up to like there are a
lot of other people who experience this
but I'm not ever letting myself connect
with people in that way because I've
just kept it pretty proud I completely
understand that as well yeah so
um
she she came out of surgery and also
this was early 2021 so everybody
especially in like the kovid ward of the
hospital is in like full astronaut
hazmat suits so if you come out of
surgery and dementia that you didn't
know you have has now gone way up and
you're seeing people like no wonder she
thought yeah
she's like what the [__] is this this is
crazy
so she was so out of it so out of and
like there's I don't know can I ask you
this it's yeah it's Maine it's covid how
would your mom at the time
two years so she just turned 70 so she
would have been like just short of her
68th birthday okay she was like 67 I
think are you allowed to even visit with
coven and everything do you have to wear
the suit too or like how's that work so
that's the thing is we couldn't visit my
mom for the first six weeks damn my mom
was in the hospital for five months
NC I complain about a month and then
there's that I hear things like this and
I'm like shut the [__] up but a month is
insane that's so over five months is
five times that I don't know how that
wouldn't make someone crazy to be honest
with you I don't know how that wouldn't
accelerate I could see myself if four
more months like if I was still in there
right now we're not even halfway through
February I would [__] be like give me
the [__] out of here I'd be losing my
[__] yeah of course especially whether
you're just like staring at the ceiling
and you're drugged a lot of the time too
for the pain and everything as well yeah
and your mom's in there for six how long
yeah five months and then you can
finally get to see her
yeah so I have a million questions I'm
sorry you know it's tell me about what
you're going through during the five
months where you can't see it can you
can you uh can she FaceTime or is there
any way to communicate with her at all
so the first six weeks they only let me
see her one time they made this it was
like a hospital exception that they were
gonna let me see her for a day I'll just
see you at the window
we got you on the ground floor on
purpose so I could do this
[Music]
we forget how amazing the show is for
making you be able to laugh at some of
these because it's like I was just
telling
um my friend before I came on here I'm
like any time that I because this is my
third time on how to do anytime you get
that thought in your brain of like oh
this would be good for the Honeydew you
know that like life is [__] bad right
then like this show is such a barometer
yeah this show is such a variety of like
how your life is going because if any
time I'm like uh like this would
probably be something to talk about on
honeydew I'm like [__]
this is a tough time I'm glad you're
tough enough to do it though and want to
because you know I yeah certainly have
been through my [__] recently and I'm
gonna do an episode about it and if
somebody so many people too are taking
shots at you while you're down and it
makes me laugh I love I love it yeah I
love it I'm like thanks for that kicking
the ribs
I got this PT yeah this leg's gonna be
bionic you was going through your
[__] chest
yeah so they let me see her for one day
in those six weeks to see if she would
recognize me it was like an experiment
because they thought well if she
recognizes her and
um it's helpful then maybe we'll make a
hospital exception that she can keep
seeing her and I went and of course my
mom is she was so out of it at the time
that like I I mean she kind of knew it
was me but it was a little in and out
and they took that as an unsuccessful
visit and I was Furious because I was
like this is so unfair like that's not
this isn't a good enough way to measure
this I think like she's on such another
planner right now you giving me a couple
hours with her is not I think a good
test of this but anyway so they
they didn't let me come back for I think
it was another couple weeks and then my
mom went catatonic and they were like it
she went catatonic I think around the
same time that their Hospital policy had
changed to like one visitor a day okay I
have to ask you this too the only way I
even know what catatonic is do you know
it's from the movie Weird Science oh you
remember the Weird Science I'm not older
than you
I mean I know of it but I haven't seen
it and it's Robert Downey Jr and they
make this girl who's Kelly LeBrock like
this beautiful whatever yeah that's
their girl and then the older brother is
Bill Paxton and he's they've somehow I
forget how it happens but the
grandparents get frozen and they're in a
closet and Bill Paxton's yelling at them
with the laundry list all the [__] he
goes and our grandparents are catatonic
in the club and that's the only reason I
even know the word so what actually is
it because the grandparents are just
Frozen in a state of like they're alive
but they're just Frozen is that what it
is yeah it it to me it doesn't like
apparelization it doesn't appear that
different from a coma okay where like
that is open no no okay
um I think they can be I think there's
probably different states of being
catatonic but my mom went into a state
where she just completely shut down her
body was just done in that moment and so
when that happened the diagnosis was
like or I'm sorry the prognosis was
maybe you're looking at like a few weeks
because if she's not really able to eat
or drink or anything like that like we
can keep her on IV fluids but then it
becomes a quality of life thing like how
long do you want her to be like this so
um in the last two years we've thought
that we were going to lose her five
different times
which I know with what you just went
through you had it's like it's crazy how
frequent those scares can be when things
start to go wrong so she has gone
catatonic I think three times whoa three
or four times and
so she ended up pulling out of that kind
of miraculously but would like dip in
and out of it and anyway I ended up
being in the hospital with her every day
for almost four months like that was the
one that's like the gift of doing comedy
for a living is that I just was like
well I'm just not gonna yeah that's me
right and I'm like I can't anyway like I
thought about it I don't think I could
stand for five minutes right now and
even do a set oh my God yeah so I get it
you're like look I can take this time
off and what's really important is this
but this is now covid's finally passed
so they're letting you come in and see
her they were letting me come in I mean
kova was still going on but they had to
loosen it a little bit we were so lucky
that I mean like
people were losing family members having
to say goodbye over iPads on FaceTime
like that was that was the only way we
could communicate with her during those
first six weeks
and did she recognize you when she
talked to you then I'm trying to I think
yes but uh it's been a couple years she
was she was just so gone it's hard to
explain but she was like not really
making any sense and
yeah then I ended up being there with
her in the hospital like it was like
eight to ten hours a day every day I
just let that kind of become my life
because
we thought she only had so much time
left they did an MRI while she was
catatonic and the way her brain looked
they were like I mean maybe you've got
yeah you're truly looking at like weeks
maybe weeks I told you they were like
top maybe like a few months because her
brain just had shrunk so much and then
so that's when they diagnosed her with
it's called frontotemporal dementia so
it's different from Alzheimer's this
affects more the front and the side
parts of your brain and it impacts
language emotion
um lots of personality changes and it
hits people a lot younger so Alzheimer's
you see more with people older often so
my mom had this much younger like in her
60s then it's much more Progressive so
it goes it develops more quickly and
just like so many times that the Health
Care system has failed her in the last
two years
yeah yeah I can't imagine years yes it's
been it's been so disheartening
um to see like she right before she was
supposed to get discharged from the
hospital I think it was like a day or
two before she fell and broke her hip
damn in the hospital because they
weren't monitoring her and like she
should not have been so then you're
right back in the [__] Hospital yeah
and then was bedridden then her hip
didn't the surgery didn't set right and
nobody had ever come to check and so
then it was just like not like it was
not fixable because they would have to
do another surgery and they're like we
don't think she would make it through
another surgery we don't think her brain
would be able to go through it so now
her hips just [__] yeah I mean that
sounds like a lawsuit doesn't it there's
so like there have been so many lawsuit
moments but I've also had a lot of
people in my life that are like you
can't win against hospitals like don't
even bother and that's very I mean
they'll probably change you dry and
that's it's like it'll be caught up in
courts for years and you just there goes
all your [__] money yeah yeah
so and it doesn't help your mom or bring
your mom back that was the thing it was
like I only have so much yeah you know
what I mean only so much time I'll also
lawsuit but but also falling and
breaking your hitting being like we're
just gonna leave it [__] up it's a
little bit like there have been so many
conversations I've had with people where
I'm like I have to be high right now
there's no way that this is like there's
no way this is really happening and so
she's just gotten uh the short end of
the stick so many times with the
healthcare system in the last couple
years and
um they after the five months in the
hospital she got discharged into an
adult family home that was about 15
minutes from where I lived in Spokane
and so I would just go be with her
um a couple times a week and but she
needed like full Around the Clock care
because now she's basically better at
end or she could be put into a
wheelchair but
yeah it's been
um it's been easily the most
heartbreaking thing I've ever gone
through these past couple years it's
been thank you it's just been so uh
yeah it's so tough nobody prepares you
for
that happening with your parent
um okay I have a lot of questions for
you yeah is this hereditary and if so
are you [__] terrified yeah so I'm
gonna do some testing soon frontal
temporal dementia is a specific thing
we're like
if my mom has this certain Gene
then it's a really really high chance
that I would have it too
but I'm I'm still trying to learn a lot
about it because it sounds like people
are finding more and more out about how
it can develop that like
um taking certain antihistamines every
day
um inhalers like Albuterol inhalers
which my mom was just always using that
all the time that's some I think they're
saying that that can lead to that too
because that's what I wanted to say I
wanted to ask is this could this be from
a car accident years ago or you know I
didn't know so really inhalers can
possibly be a cause of this that's like
recent information yeah do you ever use
the inhalers like a few times young but
not I I didn't really have intense
asthma I had some exercise induced
asthma when I was young but my mom has
always had bad asthma her whole life so
she was inhalers all the time and like
uh 24-hour antihistamines and stuff like
that so they also don't know very much
about it about this particular disease
it's less common than Alzheimer's I
believe so I don't mean to put you on
the spot here but do you know the
difference between dementia and
Alzheimer's because I don't know the
difference I know that it's they are
both under that umbrella term of
dementia all I understand so far is that
Alzheimer's hits people much later it's
like a different it's a different part
of the brain in fact in a different part
of the brain yeah people
show up
um I think they showed their signs of it
differently as well and that's what's so
heartbreaking about frontotemporal is
because its personality changes and so
it can be really it's very subtle over
time so family members don't really know
that that's even a possibility you just
think like
oh this person's kind of stressed out or
they're just kind of like yeah they're
just like behaving weirdly or getting
really emotional and this also all
happened in 2020 when everybody was
acting weird and feeling off and all
that stuff so and there was so much
isolation and I think that can really
bring out the worst of people uh and I
mean she wasn't doing anything bad it
was just like I could just tell that
something was different with her but
yeah and so where is she now in that
home she's yeah she's in that home all
right and homes always worry me too so
are they a good facility like are they
taking care of or do you know what
they're giving her and all that like are
you her like
ride or die for everything in there I've
which is unfortunate because
people tell you a lot in this process
like just focus on being the daughter
like just focus on the being the
daughter let them do their job but it's
like I have watched people [__] up and
her be the person that is impacted by
their [__] ups so often that I I don't
trust anybody anymore in that world like
I'm always double checking what's going
on with her and making sure that
everything's right because yes she's
she's had some Absolute Angels of
healthcare workers that are like the
greatest people on the planet and then
there have been people who you're like
how the [__] how did anybody let you in
here
listen again not to make this about me
no this is like it's weird that they
appreciate that because I would say like
let's just say I dealt with a hundred
different people from nerd whatever yeah
96 of them were fan [__] tastic
amazing beautiful souls kind but there
were four [__] [__] okay that
number by the way that's a phenomenal
number Cedar cyanide 96 out of 100 hey
80 plus plus okay in our health care
System yeah but those four [__]
if you don't stick up for yourself if
you are not an advocate for yourself in
our health care System then they're just
gonna [__] roll right over you or if
you don't have someone who can be an
advocate for you because when you're
just [__]
catatonic for God's sake and you have
dementia you can't even remember what
the [__] they're telling you you don't
even know anything you might forget what
the hell you're even in there for
exactly so if someone isn't there
fighting for you [__] that daughter [__]
I mean that's great I would be both I
would make a for Advocate and D for
daughter and I would just say [__] B and
C
okay forget that yes that's why
because because
I ever [__] daughter and you guys are
doing your job yeah yeah it's it's so
true though it's um have you had any
arguments like oh yeah because I you you
just strike me as such a kind person but
to have to [__] that's the other
thing too it's like they have to go
there with somebody you don't want to go
there like I didn't go there on the
first swing when the lady missed my
blood three times then I was like hey go
get somebody knows how to do their job
please Focus you know what I mean I
didn't [__] snap the first time not
even the second time it was the third
time and then when she said I did miss
and she took the [__] thing off blood
squirted on the wall and I was like well
there's the blood we needed right there
how about you go get somebody knows how
to do their job am I a dick I don't
think so you know why because that blood
oh yeah yeah there are a few of those
for sure yeah I always say on the show
too the person you know what they call
the person who finishes last in med
school doctor
you don't have to be good
yes you're like how'd you get in here
how did you [__] get in how did you
do what did you do yeah yeah that's such
a good way to put it too that um being
being kind and not being a
confrontational person I mean it is so
hard for me to speak up for myself like
I I am just not that person especially
in a medical environment because I
haven't I'm a [__] clown for a living
I don't know I don't know any of these
things and so I would see things
happening to my mom in the hospital I
would be like ah I don't love that like
that doesn't seem like the way that
should be done but you're so hesitant to
say anything and also it's that
that icky feeling of like you don't want
to rub anybody here the wrong way
because when you're not here at night
you don't know what they're doing elbows
all moms yeah I don't know for real like
there are all those horror stories but
it's true and so I was always trying I
still am trying to walk that line
between making sure she's being taken
care of
being on good terms with the people
taking care of her but like if something
goes wrong making sure they know like I
I know what's happening and so we
watched um a nurse just not give my mom
her main medication for a week a week
when do you speak up to that we didn't
know what was going on until
um
I just I was like God she's acting so
different just out of nowhere and we
know that there are these declines in
the dementia and it will keep going down
but it just
it felt like something had triggered a
decline and we were like
she's acting so much more out of it and
different than usual and so I called the
like overseen nurse
who isn't always at the home and I had
said
you know can you just check because I
don't know I just feel like something's
off and one of the nurses just had
like they there had been an issue with
getting the prescription refilled and
they just hadn't continued to follow up
so they just my mom just didn't
they just didn't say anything they just
didn't give her her main medication for
a week which completely made her go off
the rails and then it made her decline
it it's like you know there are only so
many steps that you can go down before
you are done and so that was I was livid
so what happened who did you yell at
that lady
um I yelled at the main uh the woman who
runs the home
how'd that feel when you were done
um I mean it it feels good to stand up
for what's right but you also are like I
just wish this hadn't happened because
again it's all my mom is the one who
suffers what was your
um
reaction to them when they drop when
your mom broke her hip and [__]
like did you go nuts then I would have
just been Beyond Myself yeah like who
how do you even do that yeah
and it's hard because a lot of the
excuses that were being used
during those five months in the hospital
were like well it's Kobe time like we're
short staffed there's just so much this
is just such a hard time and it's like
that is true that is a thing that I
understand is going on that is hard
however it's like
there are still things that shouldn't be
happening and that's why I felt like oh
hey I I love my mom so much and there
was just no way she was gonna be in
there without me wanting to be there are
you the only child
um I'm my I have a younger brother who's
about six years younger than me but he
lives out of state
um his wife is pregnant at the time like
just a really hard time for him to be
able to come much but
yeah it just uh I lost my train of
thought but you love your mom's oh let
me yeah yeah and oh because of covid
that
I could see that the nurses were too
loaded up they had so many patients each
that
if they would try to feed my mom and my
mom wouldn't really like take to it
they're not gonna sit there for an hour
and try to get her to eat they're just
gonna be like all right well she didn't
eat and then they're gonna go to the
next room but if I'm there I'm gonna
make sure she eats so it's like
it it sucked to feel that pressure but I
know I just knew that like because of
the situation it was in people can slip
through the cracks in the hospital so
easily yes especially if they can't um
advocate for themselves yes yeah for
sure yeah I mean I know I had nurses
coming from one will be from Monrovia
and I'm like damn he drove all the way
from Den to be Pomona and then it'd be
somewhere else I'm like damn and they're
never the same they're rotating either
floors in the same building or different
hospitals in the same network they're
never I mean if I had the same nurse
maybe two days or two nights in a row
that was like the closest you should
know in some regular person right who
knew your [__] you know what I mean
that's the other great thing is every
time a new person comes in you gotta
tell them your [__] again well I'm
originally here for a back surgery an
initiative like all the way and you get
so tired of talent but it's a new person
almost every [__] time yes exactly
and that makes it so hard too it sucks
yeah
I'm having conversations with them like
this is what you gave this is high
fructose corn syrup like we're talking
about all these health issues yeah and I
think a lot of it starts with our diet
yeah and look what you guys give us and
the nurse is like you're not wrong she
goes the same thing in schools I go
you're right giving kids and us all this
[__] all the time then we come to places
like this and then you give a [__] and
it's just a cycle yeah
I know because that's the cheap stuff so
it's just easier it's like if you want
cheese I gotta I swear to God I gotta
listen I do I'm not above a craft single
all right but I want to get it I want to
get it don't give me that in the
hospital
put it on the [__] turkey burger and
don't tell me but don't give it they
gave it to me like like somebody was
like wait wait wait he wanted cheese and
frisbee that [__] off
[Laughter]
let me buy it let me go down this Rabbit
Hole I bet you wasn't even a craft it
was probably a Kroger it was probably a
Kirkland Signature yeah it was Kroger's
a better person though definitely
because they probably had a sleeve of
them like this the purple yeah you could
launch it from across the room the way
that those things stick to anything
that's
[Laughter]
definitely what happened you know
the system respect the dust you might as
well be a star in the [__] solar
system absolutely and it's disgusting
it's so there it's just a filthy place
yeah it's really really rough all over
the country things are getting more
expensive including rent make this the
year you stop renting and buy your first
home I highly recommend checking out the
how to buy a home podcast now host David
cedoni has years of experience helping
first-time home buyers close on houses
they thought were impossible even as the
housing market went Bonkers is how to
buy a home podcast is a free resource
that breaks down what you need to know
to make buying a home a reality
including do you really need to put 20
down no most people only put 3.5 percent
will a mortgage be more than your
current monthly rent probably not do you
need an 800 credit score no people are
buying homes with credit scores in the
600s and David will tell you how David
can guide you through next steps that
are right for you he can even connect
you with the great realtor in your town
that works with first-time homebuyers
and actually cares about you and I'm
going to say this I've had several
people at least I don't know three or
four couples that have come up to me it
shows telling me that they bought their
first home because exactly this ad right
here so start listening to how to buy a
home podcast today at how to
buyahome.com or wherever you listen to
podcasts if you have questions you can
ask David directly at how to
buyahome.com visit howtobuyahome.com and
make this the last year you rent need an
afternoon reset do yourself a favor and
snag five minutes for a dad grass toke
break they've got Mom grass joints is
the perfect pick-me-up to spark your
creative flow or the original digress
joints to quiet your mind after your
nine to five that grass is legal organic
smokable hemp that relaxes your body and
Mellows your mind they're 100 organic
pre-rolled joints and flour are very low
in THC and high in CBD so you can enjoy
the effects of CBD while keeping a clear
head not looking to toke then digress
also offers the finest tinctures and
gummies on the market all the Mellow
goodness no smoke required all dag grass
products are federally legal for ages 18
and over and it ships right to your door
and anywhere in the U.S whether you're
looking for a new Buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite that grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood and right
now that grass is offering my listeners
20 off your first order when you go to
daggrass.com honeydew go to daggrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's dadgrass.com honeydew there's no
quick fix for anxiety and depression
it's not finding a new therapist or
starting an exercise routine and it's
not more in regular meditation or a
better diet I've said it before
everybody knows what's best for you
sometimes you need something to unlock
your brain a new way of thinking about
and seeing the world maybe that thing is
guided ketamine therapy from mind Bloom
there's a new tool to improve your
mental health it's at home ketamine
therapy mind Bloom is the leader in at
home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people overcome
their anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of tradition no
antidepressants in a study of over 1200
mind Bloom clients 89 reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions all
right I did this for six weeks and I'm
telling you I can't tell you actually
I'm telling you and I'm telling you I
can't tell you but I'm going to tell you
it helped me so much it really did with
my anxiety I took it for anxiety it
absolutely helped me after everything
I've been going through uh health wise
it really did allow me to think in a
different better way so right now mind
Bloom is offering my listeners 100 off
your first six session program when you
sign up at mindbloom.com Honeydew and
use promo code honeydew take the first
step and break free from your anxiety
and depression with mind Bloom
mindbloom.com honeydew and use promo
code honeydew nah
back to the do so those her five months
in the hospital
completely changed me as a person I mean
I just saw so many things that I had
never never seen before never known that
that's how the Healthcare System worked
I was so disappointed by so many things
but again like you said there are
healthcare workers out there that are
incredible it's just it just takes a few
things thank you healthcare workers yeah
for real all the seriously seriously is
RN's charge nurse is all all of you yeah
yeah because that there are some that go
so far above and beyond and those ones
you like I I mean it blows your mind
because you can't believe that they
could also be working alongside the
people who just don't give a [__] yeah I
had great surgeons that didn't big time
me and didn't make me feel stupid and I
would even tell them listen I don't I I
make people laugh for a living I'm a
clown like you said like yeah it's okay
to talk to me like I'm stupid yeah but
tell me what the [__] going on really
you know and then some of them would sit
there for 30 minutes and answer every
question I had yeah you know and I'm
like thank you thank you very much and
I've I've tried not to go to the
Internet with all this [__] because I'll
just freak myself out and I've tried to
act like it's the 80s and I'm just
listening to the doctors I haven't
Googled one thing about what's happened
to me right now because I'm terrified
good for you to read it I'm terrified
I'm gonna have to but I'm [__]
terrified to do it I'm just listening to
these doctors and going to my
appointments and doing what they say to
do yeah no I think that's I think that's
the way to do it because the internet is
uh definitely can be that black hole
feeling where you just keep going and
keep going and keep going yeah my
regular doctors like stop Googling yeah
and you're gonna you're gonna have AIDS
you're gonna think you have AIDS
it's like six degrees of everything yeah
everything leads back to AIDS but yeah
so she um
she has kind of gone up and down and is
she still there and that she's still
there right now
We There was um so in June I flew to
London to shoot a TV show I was so
excited I landed in London and had been
there for less than 24 hours when I got
a call saying your mom had a sudden
decline like we don't know if this is it
but like you might want to come back
whoa so I got back on a plane
didn't shoot the TV show just like told
my agents I was like I I could not live
with myself if I just stayed here for a
week if this is the time that this is
happening and so flew back so you're
gonna be there for a full week yeah flew
back to Spokane
she uh was basically catatonic again and
then pulled out it's so crazy to watch
somebody be truly on like the brink of
death
and then something in their brain kind
of wakes them back up again so tell me
about that did you were you there for
that like one night she's catatonic you
come in the next day and she's talking
it or how like how much she's actually
speaking and does she remember you and
so those times where she's come out of
being catatonic it's a little gradual
where she's not maybe sometimes she's
not able to say like full sentences
maybe it's just she'll like do a little
laugh here and there but her eyes will
be open which is such a massive
difference from somebody who's just
completely unresponsive and and not
taking in food or water so she's
um
she's been
she's gone on hospice like three
different times and pulled out of
hospice three different times
so I mean we're talking about the brink
of everything it yeah it feels like for
um for me it feels like you're about to
get hit by a train
and then somebody pulls that they don't
get rid of the train they just pull it
back further on the tracks because I
know that that train is gonna hit me at
some point
but it's
your mom going on hospice and being like
with doctors telling you yeah this is
probably gonna be it and then she pulls
through over and over again I mean it
it ages you 5 000 years I believe like
it's it's the most horrible draining
yeah I mean you go from the lowest to
the low to a high but knowing like you
just said that no matter what it's
coming yeah I mean what a mind [__] yeah
it keeps you in that place I can't
believe it's been two years because when
she went in like I said they were saying
she's kind of a medical miracle based on
her MRI because they were like the way
her brain looks it's like this is she's
not gonna really have much left and
she she's had moments so I I pulled her
foosball table out of storage and got it
moved into the adult family home so that
I can wheel her up in the wheelchair and
we can play a little does she play so
there were times maybe like a year ago
that she could still have some motor
skills there and could still like do
some Tic Tacs and shoot and that was so
insane to watch and I was so do those
people there know that your mom is a
Hall of Fame uh foosball player yeah so
here's and I if you don't know Kelsey's
mom is a Hall of Fame foosball player
yeah so
um what's your mom's name I'm sorry
what's your name Kathy all right so I've
started to open up about the dementia
stuff on stage during this tour and
that's one of the things I say is that
my mom's in the Foosball Hall of Fame
and every time she gets a new nurse they
always ask her about her life and my
mom's always like wow I'm in the
Foosball Hall of Fame so your mom
remembers yeah and then the nurse goes
sure you are
it's crazy
this is a weird thing to say to someone
I'll be standing there and I'm like oh
yeah no I know that sounds crazy but I
swear it's around the nurse was like hey
you don't have
yeah
it is a weird thing to say you would
think somebody would make that sounds
like you're on the street in Santa
Monica saying [__] to people it doesn't
sound like like it would be more
believable that she was in the WNBA
because at least that's like a thing
people know about
and then I'll like keep going with the
nurse I'll be like no like I I really I
could show you like trophies I can show
you videos
[Laughter]
start looking at the other nurses like
oh does the daughter have dementia too
because it's like a
family plan T-Mobile dementia that
they're on in the home oh God
but yeah it's like nobody's ever gonna
believe that in that home but
it's
not it's so unbelievable but it's true
so unbelievable dead sex is tornado
table in the middle
I know I know she's so cute playing but
I um I was there with her five days ago
and
wheeled her up to it and it's been a
little while since she's wanted to play
and her I think her some of the muscles
in her arms are starting to atrophy a
little bit because she was having
trouble even doing it and she said it
was hurting and
it was so [__]
um devastating because I was there with
her for a few hours and I know she
recognized me when I walked in she like
I bent down and hugged her in the
wheelchair and she's like I'm so proud
of you I love you so much and we had you
know a nice time our conversations now
are not really like coherent but you
know she's she'll talk to me and stuff
and then at the end of my visit with her
she just looked at me and said
and who are you again and it was oh is
that the first time yeah that's the
first time uh there was that moment in
the hospital like I mentioned really
early on but she was so she was in like
a full panic attack all the time that I
was like this just doesn't I don't know
it was a different thing this this
absolutely
knocked all the wind out of me I was so
not expecting it especially because I'd
been with her for a few hours and
everything seemed to be like that she
registered it was me
and I think she started to get kind of
tired toward the end of our visit and
I think things were kind of firing Less
in her brain but it's so chilling to
have your parent look you in the eyes
and not know who you are like that's
something that nobody can prepare you
for it disturbs you on a level like I've
been having nightmares since because it
just it
it completely [__] with I think some of
the really foundational parts of being a
human that like that is your parent
that's the person who knows you all of
those just like
yeah stuff of that that person will
always know me they'll always be my
parent my protector all of that and so
for her too in that moment not know it
was me was uh yeah that was a really bad
day that was a lot of tears that day
I'll bet yeah how did you answer it
said I'm your daughter Kelsey and she
said it oh I would be cool and I'm like
oh you're sorry yeah yeah I started to
get choked up but I was trying to not
cry hard because I didn't want to make
her feel bad or you're like I'm the
person who probably gave this Gene to
[Music]
[Laughter]
um she uh I told her it was me and she
said Okay and then a couple minutes went
by and she was like I'm just worried I'm
abandoning her
and I said who and she said Kelsey and I
said but I'm I'm Kelsey and you're
you're not abandoning me it's okay like
you know I was so emotional but what my
cousin and I have noticed my cousin
visits a lot too is sometimes my mom
thinks she's 30 years younger than she
is like if you ask her how old she'll be
like I'm 42. she just turned 70. and so
that makes in her mind me and my brother
kids
um and so I think oh that's [__]
actually that's wild it's not
interesting yeah so I think math is I'm
42 my children would be children not
this grown woman that's standing here
with me right now right so I think in
that moment it wasn't necessarily that I
didn't exist to her it's that she is
thinking I'm a child and it's oh God it
is so gut-wrenching because she has
always been the greatest Mom on the
planet and so like one of those parents
that's just always been all about her
kids making sure her kids are okay
and that to me I think is a circle of
hell that this disease has put thoughts
in her mind that like her young kids are
in a house somewhere and that she's
abandoned them that they they can't take
like that they're like where's my mom
like that's what she in those moments I
think thinks is happening so that's why
me standing there it's like well that
can't be my daughter because my daughter
is a kid
I mean this is all
I I don't know for sure but we've just
tried to kind of piece together some
things like that and um
it's not linear it's not like like I
talked to her on the phone on the way
here and
I was like hi Mom she's like hi
sweetheart like she knew it was me but
the fact that it it even happened now I
know that it's
like probably will keep happening and
yeah it's it is the longest goodbye it's
so hard it's so [__] hard
do you ever talk to her about do you
remember yesterday when you didn't
remember me do you ever talk about the
moment she doesn't remember when she's
actually with you and really like there
say like yesterday you didn't even
recognize me or do you ever do that no I
mean I'll ask her like
like I was like what did you think of
the Super Bowl to see if she would could
kind of remember watching that yesterday
but did she watch it did she did
um the way she responded sounded like
maybe she didn't fully remember she's
also here's the thing my mom is in Mensa
she's
she has her Masters in French literature
she speaks like three languages she's
one of the most brilliant people on the
planet and so I think even with dementia
there are times where she'll still try
to hide that she doesn't know how to
communicate properly anymore does she
remember the other languages she spoke
I'll speak some French with her
sometimes like that's still in there um
yeah not great but but enough yeah she
was my high school French teacher no get
the [__] up yeah what grade did you get
a nerd I was a nerd but uh yeah she was
like everybody's favorite teacher so
that's been so cool too is like whenever
I do shows in Spokane in the March line
there are always so many people that
were former students of hers that just
have so much love for her yeah but
um I try not to say anything to her that
would make her feel bad for having
dementia because she can't control it
it's not her fault I know that she
already
is just struggling so much all the time
that I think any sort of thing where I'm
like Hey do you remember that you didn't
recognize me would break her heart yeah
and it's like and then there's no point
yeah is she up and around or is she just
in a wheelchair right she's in a
wheelchair so some days she doesn't want
to leave the bed
um some days they I mean they always
like try to encourage her like let's get
into let's get you in the wheelchair and
so she can like kind of get out of the
room but
yeah it's it
it [__] sucks to know that she's like
mostly just watching TV a lot of the
days but like there's not
there aren't that many things that she
is interested in or I so I played it for
her on my laptop
um a few months ago when Sid had been
done getting edited because my my agent
actually was really smart to suggest
this he was like you know you never know
and she's had so many ups and downs like
if you have
the finished product I would watch it
with her right now while you can just in
case so I watched it with her and she um
I like dedicated to her at the end and
there's some foosball stuff at the end
and she was like tearing up for that and
was really proud so that's nice good
yeah yeah for you I feel really lucky I
gotta do that with her oh yeah yeah
yeah it's so weird to come I just talked
about this on my podcast self-helpless
for the first time but that show we like
get into
serious stuff from time to time I'm just
so used to even on honeydew with you
talking about like funnier things
sometimes it's weird to come here and
just kind of have like a very somber
therapy session well what you're going
through is not [__] yeah fun and
you're currently going through it this
isn't a story that happened to you 15
years ago right that you've gone to
therapy already about and you've dealt
with and you've thought these different
things and over time maybe your opinions
and attitudes have changed in one way or
another this is happening to you right
now so it's yeah you know it's
interesting to see where you'll be
10 years from now with this because you
also have your own concerns about your
own health yeah and I've got a genetic
thing that could kill me easily so I I'm
I'm aware of like yeah and nobody else
in my family got it they all have that
says that I'm like God damn it for real
I'm a twin I'm a twin and I got it not
my brother but that's what happens when
you're fraternal you're separate eggs
and if we were identical we'd either
both have it or not maternal on my own
zygote boom I get this stupid [__]
thing yeah I'm so sorry
yeah and you know my mom has been
divorced for
since I was five okay so that has been a
a tough part of it too is that it did
kind of all fall on me in terms of her
immediate family she didn't have a
partner or anything like that and is
your dad alive he is do you talk to him
about it yeah my end's nice my dad has
been a huge support system for me so I'm
has he visited your mom
no but they didn't have that kind of a
relationship where
um where they would have done that I
don't think my mom would have wanted
that to be honest but but my dad has
really really been there for me he was
so
so nice to have around in Spokane
especially during the hospital months
because he would like swing by the
hospital drop off food for me because I
really I would be there the whole day
and yeah that that was huge to have him
around for sure and still have him
around
but yeah so it's been it's been crazy I
was talking about the the London thing
and then
it was it two weeks after that yeah two
weeks after that I shot my special in
Denver
and I got there a couple days early
before uh before shooting the special
and I got a call from the guardian when
I got there that they were officially
putting my mom back on hospice
because the uh the London thing was a
couple weeks before that so she'd like
kind of pulled out of being catatonic
but was still not doing great
and I was just like in the comedy condo
plain old voicemails from my mom just
like bawling right before you're right
it was two days before it wasn't like I
was about to walk on stage it wasn't
like I made my mom's voice messages my
walk-on music for the special I've heard
everything Kirsten and I heard a story
I'm not gonna name the comic but um
one of the waitresses walked in and he
was like yeah that's it and she's like
excuse me he's like I'm not [__]
talking to you and then realizes that
right before he goes up he's on a
[__] sex thing with the like a live
sex thing having this girl do [__] and
and she's like that's your [__] what
that's what you're doing before you walk
up on stage and to make people laugh I'm
curious who that is
I'll tell you I'll tell you after we're
out of here for sure and you're over
there sovereign
[Music]
[Laughter]
no but it is it's like the sad clown
thing of you go on stage
tap no it's okay tap dance around make
people laugh
compartmentalize feel good for yourself
good feel good yes of course but people
have no idea unless you tell them uh in
your act what's going on and for the
last two years I haven't so I would be
having moments like that where I was
just like the lowest of low just
broken-hearted sobbing and then just
on stage
so it's
been a lot
what do you what's your biggest concern
with this for yourself moving forward
because if you don't mind me asking you
don't have to say how old are you now oh
I'm 33. all right so 33 and this hit
your mom six late 60s
so look here's the other thing you got
30 years of advancement hopefully in
medicine technology knowledge education
all of that for for all of us that have
whatever we have yeah
um
like does it scare the [__] out of you
yeah because this our job is our brain I
know it's memory it's all of that it's
being able to talk
so yeah it's it's terrifying and I also
I feel like there are
there just have been so many other
things to be thinking about that
ironically that has been the last
because in my mind I'm like well if that
does happen it's a ways away I still
want to get tested to make sure I can
like if that is the case that I can take
whatever precautions I can but just
when you do feel like the train is about
to hit with your mom you're always
focusing on that and trying to of like
my tour schedules crazy it's there's so
much going on all the time yeah and so
one thing that um I did recently which
was so hard for me to do but I moved
from Spokane to Minnesota and because
also touring out of Spokane for a year
and a half yeah you're as far away as
you can [__] be for those flights you
are every flight felt like an
international flight yeah every week
because Spokane is a tiny airport it's
way in the corner of the country no
non-stop flights maybe a couple flight
time options each day crazy time zone
changes it was like I came home every
week just a shell of a purse like it was
getting to be so hard on my body for a
year and a half so my boyfriend lived in
Minnesota
um we wanted to live together I didn't
it didn't make sense for him to come to
Spokane because then he's you know
touring too we would both be dealing
with the Spokane Airport every week but
it was so hard for me to make that
decision to move away from my mom when I
had been within 15 minutes of her for
the last couple years but um I also knew
that I feel like being that close to her
was
kind of killing me because I was
I've just cried so much the last couple
years and I learned I was looking online
I know that we're not supposed to Google
but I did Google because I was like ah
this feeling I'm gonna google I just saw
it yet not yet I'm not ready
um I found something called prolonged
grief syndrome or something like that
and I related to it a lot it's in
situations like this where it's a very
long goodbye it's not the like you don't
get a complete the grief cycle in a
normal healthy period of time it's not
like you lose somebody and you go it's
like this could be a Year's thing yeah
slowly slipping away of the person and
it kind of holds you in this mental
state that you shouldn't be in so I've
just like everything feels so hot like
every conversation with my mom I feel so
it feels so dear to me but that's like a
lot of pressure to be living like that
for two years where you want every
interaction to be amazing and perfect
and meaningful and
I think I needed I needed some distance
from it and just a healthy way so that I
could also be able to function and that
that was so hard for me because I felt
like God is that is that [__] up to
move away but there's also something to
be said for living your life and not
someone else's death
oh you know what I mean yeah that's a
powerful quote they're really wow I just
made that up look at you but I do
believe that guy like because I
understand what you're saying you're
you're in a you're in a ton you're in a
vacuum yeah a dark [__] vacuum yeah
anxiety and fear and unknown of
everything your hospice you're out you
know catatonic you're out what's gonna
happen with me you know that sort of
thing there's a lot and you're right I
mean our brain is our job here's the
thing like my business manager was like
we should talk about
um
oh what's it called uh disability
insurance and I was like you know how
[__] insurance companies are they're
going to say he's a comedian he could
roll on stage and tell jokes which I
could or I could roll up to this table
he goes yeah you could but then the guys
in the hospital are like well they're
also you could stroke and I was like I
hadn't even hadn't even considered
stroke like they keep saying [__] to me
and I'm like huh what yeah so then I'm
like well then that is my job I can't
[__] perform even if I have a stroke
you know right and do you recover fully
from that you know all these things you
start thinking about especially as we
get older with our [__] DNA yes that
we don't get to pick yeah you know what
I mean we don't get to pick anything you
just get a sign to this [__] rock in
outer space it's like this is the [__]
you got where's your card oh I'm not
gonna find out about this till my 30s
okay cool cool all right okay yeah I get
to worry about that for the rest of the
rest of my [__] life yeah dope yeah
it's it's a lot and one of my friends
who lost her mom to cancer a few years
back so she lost her you know also at a
young age
she was like your mom loves you so much
and you and your brother are her pride
and joy if you run yourself completely
into the ground
to try to help her constantly you're
doing her a disservice like she made you
so that you could go live your best live
your best life I believe as a father I'm
telling you right now will bum me out to
have my daughter there every day
wow every day I'm like go you're way
you're wasting your life God that's
wasting it you have no idea how much
that means to me to hear that from my
parents I'm not telling you my
daughter's only eight and I'm getting
chills now but I would be like go go
[__] hang out with your friends
tonight don't yeah this is a dark
[__] the place once in a while great
because I want to see you or even
FaceTime right okay so let me ask you
moving to Minnesota how has it helped
you or has it it's pretty remarkable how
even in the what's it about now five six
weeks since I've moved I I cry so much
less because I'm just not I'm just not
accessing that part of my brain as much
um I still talk to her on the phone all
the time but it
I think it's been so healthy for me just
in every way every part of my life feels
healthier of course the travel has been
so much easier and I think that just
helps everything but emotionally it
feels like that's what needed to happen
is I needed a little bit of Separation
because it was as if there was still
like an umbilical cord with me and my
mom I felt like everything she was
feeling I was feeling and that's it's a
heavy thing
well she's lucky to have you for real
thanks I'm I'm so lucky to have her
she's well we're lucky to have you this
has been I know we got to get you out of
here this has been has it been an hour
yeah look behind you we're right there
oh my God that felt like it was 10
minutes I can't believe we were able to
talk about that that whole time well
thank you for doing it I know it wasn't
easy yeah and also listen everybody
here's the thing I want to say this to
everybody I know some of us don't talk
to our family we're estranged whatever
figure out what the [__] their goddamn
medical history is if you don't talk to
them because their DNA is your [__]
DNA you can't run from that goddamn DNA
yeah so you also go get your test done
because maybe you don't maybe you don't
[__] have it maybe I don't yeah you
know there's a chance I don't
um maybe you got your dad's jeans yeah
you know yeah and I would just say if
you're seeing things in your parent that
seem unusual to you don't hesitate to
take them in like I don't think anything
would have changed if I had I mean this
was
she had the disease it was going to
happen anyway but I just um I think
sometimes we think oh our parents know
best right they're the adult they're the
adult no matter how old we get we always
think of ourselves as like we're the
child they're the parent if they say
they're okay they're okay but if you're
seeing stuff that really does make you
go I wouldn't hurt for them to like get
checked out go help them get checked out
if you can because
you just never know you never know yeah
um and I know a lot of you are probably
going through this out there so good
luck to you and everybody thank you
that's part of opening up is just to
like I would like more Community about
it because I've kept it to myself and
you do feel so isolated so I'm about to
start going to like support groups
there's support groups in Minnesota of
family members of people with uh fronto
temporal dementia so yeah I think it'll
help
um thank you again I know this was not
easy please plug promote everything yeah
so uh self-helpless podcast everywhere
you listen to podcasts my special comes
out on March 9th on YouTube
um it will be available to purchase on
my website on February 28th so that's
kelseycook.com and my website is also
where you can get all of my tour tickets
I'll be in Cincinnati Kearney
Minneapolis coming up uh San Francisco
so many tour dates so yeah go check it
out awesome thank you again and as
always Ryan sickler.com Ryan sickler on
all social media we'll talk to y'all
next week
foreign
[Music]